today you are probably expecting me to
do another Mac or Apple or iPhone video
but we're not today we're gonna be doing
my ultimate gaming PC setup this is the
Origin PC millenium and I got this for a
specific project that I was working on
we did a series of three VR videos they
were all shot in 3d and they're 180 and
we needed a PC specifically for the z
cam software that we were using huge
think it origin for sending me this that
we were able to get this project done on
time I actually did an unboxing of this
in 3d probably one of the most fun that
I've had and boxing anything ever
spoiler alert
there was a chainsaw and maybe a
flamethrower involved and they turned
out really well so you guys want to see
those I'll put a link in the description
I've been really excited to finally set
up this PC gaming station so today's the
day but I need you guys to just take a
look at this thing
shall we boot it up we needed something
that was gonna be powerful enough for VR
and this was their suggestion so let me
just open this up here so you guys can
get a really good look
since thank you super powerful it got us
through all of our VR videos that we are
working on and now it's time to finish
the gaming setup there is a monitor that
I've had my eye on since I went to CES
last year and it is finally here Wow
alright here's me freaking go wow Razer
has a theme even their power supply has
a green cable on it cool should probably
show you back look at this great cable
management we've got a bunch of other
cables here we have a DisplayPort we
have a USB C and we also have a regular
USB a connector this looks like some
green pasta I've got something else to
go with this monitor the thing that I
didn't tell you at the beginning unless
you saw the thumbnail this ultimate PC
setup has a theme and it's a color theme
and it's not green
oh there it is this is the new razor
blade 15 inch quartz I am such a huge
fan of all of their pink accessories so
my friends that's the theme of myelin to
making setup this is definitely more for
gaming on the go but when I'm at home
obviously I'm using the origin PC as my
desktop situation situation what is this
situation my I don't do I can't even
think of a better word so over the past
few years I've been collecting all of
the accessories from the razor in quartz
lime and now it is finally time to put
them all together in my ultimate PC
gaming setup
[Music]
here it is this is honestly been
something that I've wanted to set up for
so long I finally have all of the pieces
everything is together and it is a pink
dream so now let's go through everything
that I have set up one of the best parts
about this is these Corsair fans that
are in here are all controlled by an app
all of the razer LED lights are also
controlled by an app so i can basically
make these any other color that i want
but why would i want to do that this is
my pink setup you can judge me all you
want because i know you're gonna do it
but i don't care these side lights that
we have are mostly just for shooting but
these things are so great let me just
show you this real quick these are man
lights so these really cool tube lights
that you can control all of the colors
and this is like my new favorite thing
that we got for the studio make shots
look great so of course the centerpiece
to all of this is the origin millenium
PC so this is a special edition unlock
to ninth dad Intel Core i nine we've got
an 8 gig nvidia geforce r-tx 2080 Super
Ventus GPU 32 gigs of DDR 4 RAM 1
terabyte western digital SSD 12
terabytes Seagate Barracuda mechanical
hard drive corsair RGB premium fans and
holding everything together we have an
MSI Z 390 gaming edge AC motherboard I
do need to work a little bit on the
cable management but I did set this up
pretty quickly so all things considered
I think it looks pretty good
let's first show you guys the Razer
synapse app you may have seen this
before if you're familiar with all of
razor's accessories but this thing is
awesome here you can see everything that
we have connected each of these
accessories is easily configured through
the app so for example when you click
into the mouse you can customize
performance lighting anything
librated there's a bunch of quick
effects there's advanced effects but if
you just want to have a static color
that's super easy just pick the color
that you want and that will just be a
static color it's super customizable and
you can do that for all your peripherals
so this is the corsair IQ app course
there also has a lot of really great LED
accessories so if you have their
keyboards or their mice or if you have
some of them installed in the RGB fans
that can also all be controlled here
through the IQF i'm pretty happy with
these colors so i think we're just gonna
leave it how it is but if I wanted to I
could spend hours customizing all the
colors and synchronization to what's on
my screen I'm not gonna do that right
now because I've got more to show you
over here we have my custom camo xbox I
would say it's one of a kind but it's
actually two of a kind this is actually
made for a charity event last year so I
got one and also someone who
participated in the charity event also
got one and I know it's not plugged in
yet but it will be obviously we've got
our mouse keyboard we've got a nice
quartz pink microphone this one actually
doesn't have any lights on it if you got
a 15 inch quartz played laptop that you
saw me unbox earlier in this video and
then I know this is a PC setup but I'm a
Justine and I couldn't help it over here
is my pink 16 inch MacBook Pro I'm sure
many of you guys are very familiar with
D brand and a huge thank you to them for
supporting my channel this is one of the
new pink skins that they have and they
not only have this for the laptop but
they have them for so many other
accessories I've been such a huge fan of
d-brane for so long so you guys are the
best under here this is actually another
pair of headphones these ones I mostly
use when I'm playing xbox and then under
under here these things are amazing so
these are specifically designed for Xbox
these are a 4d experience they give you
haptic feedback when you're playing
games so it's kind of like a little
vibration you can adjust the levels if
it's a little bit too aggressive for you
but these have been so much fun when I'm
playing Call of Duty and yeah they're so
massive but they're really light so it
doesn't really feel like they're that
huge that's it my Alta PC gaming setup
let me know what you guys think I forgot
it I forgot to mention my art so these
are some paintings
friend Susie got for me a few years ago
and finally they now have a home I love
the fact that we kinda have like a
little gradient happening here the pink
leading into the purplish lights and we
have our blue little Maddy beautiful oh
I almost forgot underneath the desk is
this Jackson bones bed that Maddie
he's a doggy ambassador for Jackson
bones I just want to say he's famous
he loves to sit underneath of my desk
when I'm working or editing or gaming
not so much when I'm gaming because I
started yelling and flailing my balloons
around so usually he sits those ones out
thank you guys so much for checking out
this video I had so much fun putting it
all together let me know if there's
anything else you think that is missing
from this gaming setup maybe pink gaming
chair don't forget to like this video
and subscribe if you enjoyed it and I
will see you guys in my next video
[Music]
I also got a small injury because I
dropped the monitor on my finger I it's
like a blood blister at least it's pink